as if the 40 seconds of logos wasn't
enough all three of them are different
Sony logos we get it just bring on the
unnecessary mining of our rabbit based
childhood nostalgia already if there's
one thing I really want from a movie
it's to kick off with birds singing
cliché phrases from motivational posters
yeah sorry about that
that's not the story where it's having
hair Asian movie title is somehow a part
of the physical world of the movie are
they the same size is what be consistent
with this it's their air you don't know
any cuts gross angry everyone cuts grass
angry I intently watch all my neighbors
do their yard work and none of them
looks happy when they see me staring at
them from behind the curtains really
does that all works my life will be
pleased to hear this I don't know why
I'm salad it's the dressing get it on
the side so begins a terribly
frustrating theme in this movie what the
animals do and don't know about real
life chubby bunny would be excellent at
cinemasins
Cottontail has great aim and a hell of
an iron one would almost have to be a
Jedi with the force and unimpressive
parents to be able to make that shot if
I sigh at the same time as rolling my
eyes can I call it a sigh roll yes or no
I can't see through the gate no no no no
I think you said yes Peter apparently
went to the Brett Ratner school of
hearing things I'm gonna put you in a
pie like I get your dodge how exactly
does Alan grant McGregor know that he
killed this random rabbits father
watercolors position animation within
animation that's like 16 narrations Wow
McGregor just slammed that pole in there
without even digging the hole first dude
must be jack or small or whatever the
hell kids are saying these days sorry
kids unless one of your parents kicks it
your story will never be good enough to
chill in an animated film he was hoping
also not to say that old man McGregor is
not a right old tosser but it is his
garden and his vegetables that he bought
with his money at this point I'm not
sure why we aren't team McGregor here
whoa Peter Rabbit just went dark young
Peter not only sees his dad get reek
slammed he has to watch him be served up
in a pie
Beatrix Potter was like the Lars von
Trier of
children's authors I promise I'll always
be here for you and she has ever since
their mother died but her death wasn't
as tragic so no need to go into that
story
knew he is God because even though I
can't communicate with you and somehow
knew that the jacket was very important
to you when you would come back to get
it Ruby says few to anyone fortunate
enough to have never heard steal my
sunshine countlessly on the radio in
1999 oh I thought they were never gonna
have to hear it again also these rabbits
realize there's not an unlimited supply
of food right McGregor is not there to
plant the vegetables then they won't
grow any more they understand the
concepts of what subterfuge and salad
dressing is so why the crap don't they
understand gardening thank you for the
party was pickling eating celery it's a
shame when you don't know who you are
but big wing is a pig and so therefore
he's an omnivore which means he will eat
anything
and celery would definitely fall into
this category of anything bad Tommy
you're one of the good ones that's
racist look can't be more inclined to
believe in walking talking rabbits than
I would that you could possibly open a
door this way also for a slob that is so
self negligent that he's headed for an
early death McGregor's house is
amazingly clean so in the time it takes
them to track down Thomas no one
involved with the estate holdings came
by to check on the house maybe lock the
door and or kick all the animals that
had taken up residence out and while B
seems more than okay with a rabbit
stealing from McGregor's garden I'm not
so sure he would just let them destroy
the house also Animal House mr. McGregor
will torment us no Jesus movie we get it
this premature celebration is so
premature that these rabbits should be
NASA employees you're seeing him at his
happiest I think you mean hook seus I
have some bad news Thomas your
great-uncle passed away they contacted
his place of work and made his employer
tell him this why wouldn't they just
give him a call or send them a letter or
do anything but this
manaman congratulations
no one starts a conversation like this
unless they're reading from a script for
children's film where every little last
detail has to be explained now it's a
party
well no one's wearing pants this entire
movie so I guess it's been a party for a
while
Harold and Kumar would be proud also I
get that they're raging and but why are
they spending so much time in the house
don't wild animals like to be on time
are they abandoning their natural
habitat just so they can throw each
other at a wall I don't know anyone from
Wyndemere it's been unclaimed property
huge remains you've inherited something
if whomever sent this information knows
where Thomas lives why didn't they use
that address to let him know about the
death that's all well maybe Thomas can't
actually hear the goose speaking he'd
definitely be able to hear whatever the
hell noise it's making not to mention
all the animals running around and
making noise you know like we're all
connected but with what rope plays Peter
acting hi our carrots like the marijuana
of the animal kingdom or is he just
hoping to score some Cottontail even
though humans can't understand when the
animals talk all the different species
of animals can easily communicate with
each other
geez movie secret life of pets much just
because you can't see him doesn't mean
he can't see you understand sure makes
sense to me but what doesn't make sense
is how you knew it was a him that was
approaching and the deductive reasoning
of these animals is astounding not only
do they know what a pinky is they
immediately assume that this dude is a
descendant and not like a caretaker or a
real estate agent it wasn't a knight as
OCD as the movie has made Thomas the
wing congenita be he still was somehow
able to sleep in a room as disgusting as
this at least someone's still using a
blackberry also these rabbits have wet
wipes hidden somewhere weird and all
that fruit whose go thank you
those look like expensive ass binoculars
B just met this mother Karen handed over
a pair of $200 Orion's I don't care I'm
going in - Peter have such a boner for
this house anyway I know his father was
killed and all but he got vengeance on
the old man and the vegetable garden
should be already decimated at this
point I realize we are playing fast and
loose with reality here but how did he
teleport there so quickly is his actual
name Nightcrawler MacGregor dr.
Manhattan MacGregor this rabbit shell
game is clever funny and full of the wit
seen throughout the film I mean it ain't
patent
or anything but it's still worth us in
awe for so many smiles yeah I totally
can't hear a single word of this
detailed joke conversation we're having
why am I talking to wildlife make up
your mind movie are you gonna be a
self-aware a satirical take on a
children's classic or are you going to
intentionally be stupid fine the animals
can talk and do humanistic things but if
they've never left the garden area how
the hell would Peter know enough about
this car to do this so Peter is able to
get the hood back open to free his ear
but somehow the hood is back down in the
very next scene and Peter is acting as
if this is right after his ear was
caught where did he hide when Thomas
closed the hood the second time and or
how did the hood cause all by itself
yeah we don't inherit the earth we
borrow it I read that on a plastic cup
not only does Peter know what a plastic
cup is he can read we emit smoky which
is why I think she's just got a thing
for those rabbits which is why I think
she's just got the thing for most man
but no lip reader would mistake rabbits
for man buts it's almost as if the movie
wanted to say butts and get a cheap
laugh but never of what movie turns
real-world physics on and off depending
on if it suits the joke these hitch
hopping rabbits will spend the next 20
seconds hanging out of this window and
will never be seen despite being
completely invisible in the rear view
mirror I'm allergic to blackberries very
shadowy some people do have legitimate
medical conditions of course of course
it's a real struggle my heart goes out
some it's very tough very sad I'd only
get any letters now we've got a fourth
wall break that references the impending
controversy about food allergies Jesus
Christ movie pick a lane Berman what
does Fuhrman mean like a rodent Peter
knows what allergies are along with
everything else he's talked about in
this film but not vermin or rodents he
sure did get pretty lucky to peel the
exact tiles to create the most on the
nose words pointing to their own
character traits huh peel heel
you can't call peel when you still have
tiles unused what kind of anarchist
loosey-goosey gamma Bananagrams is this
rotten banana I say like people who
aren't who they say they are the hotels
boys she doesn't like the one thing he
is and will eventually figure this out
but then it will all come down to a
misunderstanding and there will be a big
change in character and they will fall
in love and live happily ever after
cliche
with Tara did listen to worse actually
it is which the movie will explain
though it's often spelled with two R's
however I'm sitting this because there's
no way these two appealed enough tiles
for either one of them to call bananas
you're supposed to keep peeling until
there aren't enough tiles for everyone
to peel again and only then can someone
call bananas and since they've only
filled four tiles since we saw this many
left in the bag I call banana ground
Finnegan's banana goons shenana grams
Herbal Essence Inge sorry to interrupt
this interspecies WrestleMania with some
facts but if that rabbit took a full
domhnall gleeson it would cease to exist
it would be no more that is an ex rabbit
rabbit Bunch
wait is this from the paintings POV if
not why is the blue paint hovering in
the air and if it is wouldn't all the
other paint be on there too where is
camera it's ruined
you know how unconsolable wildlife can
be she's seriously blaming a rabbit for
this while it's clear that B would be
annoying she has to realize that Thomas
either had something to do with it or
did nothing to stop it
also Thomas's reaction here would imply
that he is literally setting a rabbit up
and assumes that the rabbit also
understands that he's being set up
I guess he wishes someone cock-blocked
him sorry I had to also haven't seen
this many rooster jokes in a movie since
that 15th anniversary sing-along
screening of raqqa doodle antonin last
year
I mean went to in costume I mean why you
kids walking so slow and that is how you
sneak up on someone actually it's not if
you were walking in slow motion there is
a much greater chance that they'll see
you sneaking up on them the rabbits
managed to home alone Thomas but even
Harry and Mara would be able to
anticipate these Purana traps that'll do
two hedgehogs not shoot their quills on
like a porcupine the quills don't even
detach from their body very easily also
mrs. tiggy-winkle survives this
seriously what's the fucking point of
the electric fence if it can't take out
one faceless Hedgehog
this works receding hairline
[Music]
oh sure these bunny geniuses know how to
rewire electricity when they need to but
don't try to run out of this hole as
soon as explosives are dropped in pick
an animal like you movie I think I've
got some kind of ulterior motive because
of losing my own mother and father and I
think if she goes what have I got this
movie doesn't go for B movie on us and
end with these two on their bunny moon
together but here's a sin anyway for the
sting of dangling us so close to that
one B you can see he's getting pelted in
the nuts with vegetables right we have
the same view she does okay so Peters
clearly been killed based on the
sequence of events not how I would have
been to the kids movie but at least it's
over damn it these people have used
explosives before to keep the rabbits
out explosives how exactly does Thomas
think all of this will work out if he
wants to bang B he probably needs to let
the rabbit thing go how was he going to
explain it if he blew up the tree the
previous night where did these bright
green stains come from when the last of
the berries had been flung they were
nowhere to be seen and what fruit
vegetable would even make such a stain
let's get away from this evil man
since when does this rabbit have a
conscience
he literally thought he murdered this
man twice and has hopped along his merry
way but a little breakup brings along
the rabbit tears this wasn't part of the
plan huh this is was it always has been
exactly the plan how is the garden this
meticulously maintained especially after
all the explosions thing I just happened
to be walking by my former place of
employment and home to horrible memories
for no apparent reason that I'm scared
Peeta don't be I'm gonna fix this why
are they so scared in fact the MacGregor
house is back open
why aren't they infiltrating that again
and if not them the rest of the wildlife
that was there last time oh sorry sorry
for these six hundred tenth time in this
movie I've yelled how does nobody see
this obvious rabbit at my screen do such
a thing I have many enemies well there's
no one else out here except these two in
rabbits so was this that heart of a
deduction started I think this entire
movie is from the perspective of a
delusional beat hey rabbit even though
benjamin has never been to the city and
has been shown to be about as smart as a
bag of carrots he knows immediately to
go in robot rabbit
Oh cold wait so now Thomas can hear
Peter talking or is this his heart as
Peter says later they've been talking
around him and B this entire fucking
movie but only now he can hear him god I
swear this movie is making it up as it
goes along it was dangerous
gutsy convoluted and in a story like
this pretty much a journey guaranteed to
succeed self excusing me rest position
what is this a Deadpool movie world
where animals can talk and scheme why
didn't they just tell him what the plan
was instead of slapping his dear rear
he's had this in his jacket the whole
time he ran and jumped on and rode a
train was chased all over the toy store
and had to get back to Wyndemere
but somehow never dropped the one thing
that would keep B from leaving good
thing they still had all this set up and
ready to go and time to shock the new
homeowners how did they organize this
party so quickly
is there a bat signal Peter can throw up
that indicates some crazy shenanigans
are in order nothing says the right
director for a kid's film like a
filmography of sexual coming-of-age
films like fired up eza and
friends-with-benefits oh good the movie
is still going apparently the role of
Peter was played by the Energizer Bunny
since it just keeps going and going and
going
a b-rabbit bitch sting like a bee
look at him pure evil like the fruits of
the devil the thing is this is their
gift okay they're built to be thrown
like a lawn dart they're top-heavy like
a lawn dart to their bill for accuracy
my opinion it's just the most beautiful
place on earth did you design Ava's face
based on my pornography profile young
rabbit in a blue coat pan no hands
sometimes your pants will come off but I
was not fortunate enough to see the
pants portion on this strike why are you
afraid I'm gonna get my foot caught in a
trap and I'll have to annoy daughter
town bitch
so you're promoting a flagrantly
unqualified half-wit
to obsession of immense importance based
purely on nepotism you're young and you
got your Heil what you want with the job
I am the man with no name Zapp Branigan
that's your service love is infinite
look man I follow for no banana in my
tailpipe